so Tony sorry it's Sam no are you go in
terms of your cut yeah we're all set
we're all set we actually have
contracted in hand for you get a sign
that is very very exciting
very very exciting did you have fun
dealing with the Sirius XM personnel for
the last month or so
I don't know fun is the best word but
it's know they were they you know what
this month is when it really everyone
got got very active and they were really
everyone was working hard to get it done
and they had other stuff they're doing -
I mean their lawyers do everybody and
there's you know hundreds of people
working here yeah so I'm just glad we
got it done yeah but I mean it was an
important deal for them I mean like
everyone was working really hard I mean
everyone for you know so if you know it
got all the way to Jim Meier and Scott
green scene Andrew Andrew Andrew more
Moss and then and then of course Gary
she's got a bad show on whether is that
a bad sign when your agent just another
name names of the people drew so many
different people about this deal but but
everyone was working very hard and very
active to get it done did the point and
it were they weirded out when I said
that from now on their call me mr.
Norton I would like a little respect
around here I'm tired of the data that
they actually could cut that out
couldn't win that battle yeah but when
you go down the hall and talk to them
and like you like all rights never
Pleasant negotiating but when you're
like look this is what we want to kind
of get done they're always alright yeah
we want to get it done so it's it's
easier just to keep it friendly and not
be so aggressive I mean there yeah yeah
well they want us here yeah yeah I mean
they're doing their job we're doing our
job and then you know everything's a
compromise but you guys you guys got a
really great deal and every was excited
to have you three in three more years
that's the big announcement three years
we shine this deal the first contract
was two years we're signing today for
three years here at Sirius which I'm
excited about
I am too I know one year is great but I
can't live year-to-year I just can't do
it I guess it's too panic-stricken six
months out you're already like I read
[ __ ] we got six months to start yet just
do three years yeah you do there is this
feeling of like you know we'll be
alright we got three years
yeah figure it all out right we have
three years to figure out whatever
whatever we have to do in three years we
have three years to figure that I think
you guys already figure it out you guys
doing a great job but it does it goes
quick it does go yeah the two years one
really fast and then you start you know
I like to know I have a gig I love this
gig and you like to know you have a
place you're gonna pay your mortgage
yeah and your shit's gonna get done
right you know it's like I forget like
just being a stand-up you don't have a
regular gig of course off a regular
check oh yeah and you else I've got a
whole group of people to work with you
I'm sure so it's nice to know they've
got some stability too yes yeah now what
is what Travis what is your deal up like
you how long were you here he'll what I
can tell he's being sarcastic not eating
how long are you are you just you're an
employee so you don't go yeah Travis is
15 year contract is almost up so we'll
have to renegotiate that so they just
they don't renew you every so often no
I'm just an employee okay yeah at will
yeah well mmhmm yep I work for the
company at their pleasure but what like
Helen how many years is the deal of
would have to give raises or whatever
it's just have you ever worked anywhere
[Laughter]
sort of like that many years since I've
had a been an independent contractor for
so many years that it's always been this
way I'm a salaried employee raises
usually come along once a year always
once a year okay bonuses come along once
a year Oh usually usually not always
okay usually yeah it's been a long time
I'm not on a contract Troy's not on a
contract Travis got very excited because
he told me before the show Tony asked
for his number and Travis goes oh I
guess somebody has acknowledged my
talents as well somebody's figured out
that the Travis dog has something to
offer yes Tony I what did you want for
breakfast the best part is I don't even
know his last name
aside from Tefft that's all you need te
FFT it's a theft tax and I hope this
week you're picking up I'm dying to know
because I want to temps in my home
that's right you can sing it to them as
they're in your home you know how much
credit would you say serious just put
out an article about how much money they
made this quarter right was it a good
article a great art rate oh yeah we did
the company did extremely well this last
corner how much of that was ours most at
70 80 % Wow yeah that's good part about
higher than I thought gave us a little
stronger position and negotiating that's
great yeah good actually all right what
doc
well I don't want even the market has
been shitty though exactly the markets
been very bad you know one of the things
we were trying to forget like what to do
for gift obviously alcohol was off the
table for both of you so that took a lot
of our ideas off but then we said we
should get you the the Apple Genius just
get a guy like on call I discovered the
chip pas de cash was not on Spotify I
had to call Roger Cassidy what the
[ __ ] going on and they fixed it good
but I understand it's also get me played
on this platform we just don't know
where that's at for me yeah in the
Sirius XM platform it's gonna be a week
later I believe the chip podcast is
going now err on Sirius XM that's very
exciting I'm assuming on this channel I
don't know whoever they want you know
that's that's a great question I assume
it's gonna be on this channel I think
it's gonna be on this channel on the
weekends but it's gonna be yes so week
because you've comes out Sundays right
yes it does yeah so so a week till a
Sunday I think it's gonna air on this
channel but Jim McClure might know yeah
maybe it'll be on raw dog to Jim Myers
demanded it him and then Scott the top
brass are all chip fans that's right it
is amazing I'm not you know sharing
trade secrets but it is amazing how much
time and energy was spent and shift chip
person when it came to our negotiations
I literally was saying sometimes to the
business of air guys I can't believe
we're saying chip chip person as a real
person and how much and both sides were
digging in over chip chip person and the
podcast and the delay and all of this
what is this week I would call it Jim
I'm like do you realize how much energy
chip-chip person is sucking from my life
right the fact that Jim Myers whose runs
this and I has to hear the name
chip-chip person do you know how happy
it made Scott and [ __ ] Andrew Moss
and all the head lawyers have to deal
with chip chip person when we were
coming in in September and sounding
frustrated about this whole thing and I
was saying we'll tell you what the
slowdown is but you're not gonna believe
this chip trip erson was slowing down
both of our life if ship person was it
was that was the holdup was chip it was
it was I don't think we would have I
don't think we would have had to end up
signing three weeks worth of extensions
or four weeks worth of extensions or
whatever it was if not for chip chip
ursin because what happened was and then
again I'll be I'll be vague about it but
you know riot cast does chip and then
they let me do it chip here they didn't
have to let me do chip they let me do it
on a handshake car but yeah guy had to
do it in the middle of a contract they
were cool about it here and they could
have said no because the way the certain
things are structured so then when the
contract is up now I have to kind of get
permission to do it so it's a whole
[ __ ] thing yeah yeah becomes a thing
yes and chip held us both up you know a
chip one's breakfast every day - of
course he does delivery would [ __ ]
respect
yeah the fact that that probably wants
bikini chicks to bring it to him dude
there was one point I'll tell you this
Gary was actually very helpful you know
Gary Shawn what do I know a long time
and we have relations yeah sure Gary's
been a part of the channel and you know
he's now he's moved up you know in it's
a high-profile figure around dude you
all you never you can't just it's like
[ __ ] with the intern who then becomes
your boss and you never know who you're
[ __ ] with right we always got along
with Gary other people didn't we always
did yes and now Gary is one of the guys
you have to [ __ ] deal with on
contract level yeah
Gary doesn't you know Gary is way high
up right thank God no matter what was
happening on the air we were always cool
with him and I mean you know he's
friends with Gary and so I knew that
talking to him he and I had one
conversation I just called him and you
know we both were on opposite ends of
this but we again it was a friendly
there's no anger you know I know the guy
so one point we're talking about chip
and I was so frustrated I'm like I'll
stop doing the podcast I'm like Gary
I'll just stop doing the [ __ ] podcast
and he said to me he goes well it might
be a deal breaker he goes because Jim
Meyers wants to say that he said it's a
they want chip it was it was literally
the greatest moment and the most
humiliating moment of my career that
they were real willing to let me walk
right ship might be or they wouldn't let
Jim and Sam go down the toilet over chip
yeah I kind of want a hug Gary for
saying that it was one of the best and
worst moments of my career absolutely
right because we were literally like 95%
through it and we're like saying right
well so then chip was just stopped
podcasting and Andrew said I think the
deal's off
wanted chip I would have loved to hear
that phone call from Tony Sam
we've reached a real slow down here
we're gonna try to figure something out
for you I it's not looking good though
they they need chip and it's become a
deal breaker
what so this is gonna be chips here I
can sense it really 20:19 no it's not me
Jim Norton's here but literally my whole
[ __ ] professional life was held up by
that [ __ ] altar he's an enemy so yeah
you know what he knows that dude what's
even worse so was mine the whole thing I
mean a lot of times I don't even share
like you know how ugly or justjust like
frustrating it was getting so it was
better just not to give you the
play-by-play yeah no no no I've always
had a kind of love/hate thing this would
really shift it in a certain direction I
like to know what's going on like I like
to be kind of kept abreast of what's
going on even though I know it's it's a
mess it's a mess early like I know that
yeah I guess what if AJ poopy shits was
holding up the deal Tony would probably
keep that information from you
understand probably wouldn't land well
with yeah it would not which is on the
level of what's going what went on here
the whole thing was held up by shepherds
that was what it was I love it it was
crazy
in hindsight now that all's well that
ends well I absolutely adore that that's
what happened yeah but I'm afraid that
that's gonna be brought up on the
podcast and it's gonna be you that you
think the chimp is gonna start
humiliation humiliated I believe that
that will happen too so yeah thanks to
only a good job I'm gonna peruse the
contractor and during the break the one
the one that said she's lazy but
judgment I love that I'm doing my due
diligence during the break I'm trying to
peruse it yeah I gave you the old sign
Sookie we stay pretty uh in close touch
about things and I feel pretty good yeah
no I mean honestly you like it we try
not to over share just because it's all
negotiation and you don't wanna someone
have to be disappointed that you're
through working on something you what
you don't get when you do get we got a
lot we got a lot here and and we kept
you abreast along the way but you know
you really good I mean you'd been
through this process you knew what to
expect I was actually concerned for you
just because having not had an agent do
this before you'd know to expect and you
were great yeah and you were patient and
you're great and you asked all the right
questions I sent I was very strategic I
sent Tony
a photo of my action figure collection
but I waited until the contracts were
completely done I wanted I familiarized
him with that side of myself but waited
until everything was done because you
know what there's a slight chance he may
not have taken me seriously as a client
if he had known going in to see you at a
bunch of shirtless men dolls actually I
think it was a good chance I might not
have signed you that photo before that
was honestly shocking and alarming at
many levels to see that yeah it's really
creepy and OCD there's a lot too Sam
you'll get to know that he seems like
he's just a regular dude but he really
is a [ __ ] manchild creep there's
something dark in his past what are you
talking about I had a girl telling me
she's convinced you've been molested who
said that just a friend of mine she's
convinced you've been molest well how
would she know anyway your food choices
oh she's like that's very common people
have been molested only childish food
but it might just be a coincidence you
know it could be and you've never had a
drink that's a little no no but neither
is our great president okay so that
doesn't make it any better okay have you
never drank it all no no no all you'd
ever try beer I want to see Sam drunk
God would that be great you don't know
an obsessive person I know it's either
all in yeah or all I see your life
spoiled by alcohol understand like
everything has been set up like I spent
35 years just delicately setting
everything up so perfectly paying
attention to every detail everything is
set up properly just in an instant
watching it all spiral just [ __ ] it
all up you know it's so good because we
actually spent a lot of time and energy
on but the morals and terminations so we
get into this whole part about you know
alcohol and drugs and thankfully for you
two I mean which is such a pleasure as
an agent like you two we don't have to
worry about in many ways but like all I
can think about is if you decided to
have that one sip this is why we need
all this stuff in the contract right
right just the spiral what you want to
see the spiral to you oh my god I try to
get him high so many times just the hot
wouldn't be as bad he tries to get me to
do Troy does try to get me to do drugs a
lot that's tells me they're cool they're
not fine on the rapper's do them right
if you want to be cool like me you gotta
smoke a little of this he says that but
you know what I'd tell him I have a toy
collection I say wow
and I learned this from some of those I
say I'm not a chicken you're a turkey oh
you should try pot once you have no
desire to try - are you sure you afraid
you'd like it no I have no desire okay
yeah I don't have any actually that of
all the things you're gonna try that
would be the one thing to try because it
would just like it would chill you out
and you know rage just trying to get
your high no no let me qualify this I
don't want you to do anything but if
you're gonna do one thing but it's also
why go to all it ever is smoking pot if
to get some pie if to put it in the damn
okay I'll put it you'll pack your ball
fob I'll pack it right off I don't want
to do you there's some I just do pills
what's your vape can you like do you
like chocolate chip cookies gonna have a
chocolate of cookie like my mom or he
makes good chocolate chip cookie
lapatinib she's probably do it for years
I don't know it Mother's been drugging
your cookies for eight yeah that's why
I'm so paranoid Sammi hooked yeah he's
Sammy coming home his munchausen
syndrome by proxy except weed yeah she's
putting drugs in your cookies right like
the like the mom in the sixth sense just
Drano and weed I kid deserved it that
[ __ ] puppet show Mischa Barton I was
terrible awful awful just vomit all over
herself
well good Tony I'm really happy me too
so take away we're not doing pot we're
not smoking or not drinking or not doing
anything I know well I'm gonna sign the
contract and then we're gonna try I mean
then it's a whole relapse yeah we got
three years guaranteed yeah [ __ ] it
you know let's do crazy [ __ ] yeah you
should read your contract a little more
I trust you Tony we're gonna go on party
we gotta celebrate let's do some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah within the confines
of your termination clause that's fine
and they say that we can't even be fired
for screaming racial things that's right
that maybe that's not true I try to have
that point we could scream it everyone
on the corner makes a virus right